dragon flies can fly upside down hover
turn 360 degrees on a dime and reach
speeds of up to 55 km/h they can even
fly backwards with as much skill as they
fly forwards now researchers have
figured out how scientists captured over
40 dragon flies from the wild and placed
dots along their wings for tracking they
then recorded their flight with
high-speed cameras when the scientists
analyzed the videos they discovered
backward flying dragonflies angle their
bodies upward at a 90 degree angle to
the horizon this changes the direction
of force generated by the wings through
whole body rotation instead of only
changing the way their wings are
oriented this style of flight use
sometimes in helicopters was found to be
surprisingly aerodynamic in dragonflies
when moving backwards the dragonfly's
wings can generate force as high as two
or three times the bugs body weight this
work may help engineers design more
acrobatic aerial robots even backward
flying ones
[Music]
you